مستويات قياسيه للدولار في السوق
الايرانيه ولا مؤشرات لعوده الهدوء فقد
تجاوز سعر الدولار حاجز 60 الف تومان
ليسجل زياده منذ منتصف فبراير باكثر من
ثلاثين بالمئه في مقابل التومان كل هذه
التطورات تاتي رغم انشاء الحكومه مركزا من
اجل تبادل العملات والذهب لاداره سوق
الصرف الاجنبي خاصه بعد تقلص تعاملات
ايران مع العراق بضغط من الولايات المتحده
عقب اكتشاف تهريب ملايين الدولارات من
البنوك العراقيه الى طهران اخطر ما في
الموضوع ان علي رضا ممثل تبريز في
البرلمان نقل عن محمد مخبر النائب الاول
للرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي قوله انه ليس لدى
النظام حل افضل اداره سوق العملات قالها
بوضوح هذا كل ما لدينا دفعت هذه المواقف
عددا من النواب الى شن هجوم حاد على
الفريق الاقتصادي في حكومه ابراهيم رئيسي
[موسيقى]
المديريات فان كورونا
جرامي لنطق
الروم ياه
فكانوا يا اساسي
برايستيس اه ياما
جهودك
وفق تقرير لمركز الاحصاء الايراني فان
معدل التضخم في فبراير الحالي بلغ ثلاثه
وخمسين بالمئه واربعه اعشار النقطه
المئويه بزياده اثنين فاصل واحد بالمئه
مقارنه بالشهر السابق وبسبب هذا التضخم
الكبير تحولت انظاره الايرانيين للبحث عن
ملاذذات امنه تحفظ مدخراتهم وهذا ما ينذر
بمزيد من الصعوبات التي تنتظر التومان